The Joe Rogan Experience borderline like
psychotic episode from your perspective
you don't even understand what a drug is
that to take you there's no frame of
reference like first time I did ask that
I was scared but I knew that I was about
to be on a [__] Journey you know what
I'm saying that was the idea
um when you're a kid and it comes out of
nowhere so you accidentally take it and
then it's just you're just in this state
yeah and then you know now you know
that's possible so you're always going
to have this anxiety that at one point
in time you might slip back into it that
was the thing that I had always heard
about acid too that scared me when I was
a kid flashbacks yeah flashbacks you
would tell you they would tell you bro
it stays in your fat yeah the acid stays
in your fat man and one day you're just
[__] driving down the road and the
road becomes teardrops like what yeah
man you have a flashback people died
that way I was like it was like always
the thing like if you take acid like
maybe you'll never come back yeah I
think I took so much acid one time the
most asset I ever took when I was 19
years old maybe 18.
um me and my buddy Dan Doherty we got a
medicine dropper this [__] hippie kid
this [__] real big known hippie in my
town he's like dude I got acid and when
when hallucinogens came to town in New
York where I was at Rockland County New
York when hallucinogens came around in
the early 2000s late 90s you got them
because they only came around once in a
while there'd be like a [__] hippie
Festival Upstate and like people bring
strips of acid down or they would have
mushrooms but it was so rare so we when
you would hear about somebody having it
you'd [__] drive we used to drive
from Rockland County which is right
outside of New York City this is Robert
to Albany because there was a guy that
would get it up there and we would
[__] pick it up when he had it he had
it like twice a year
um but this kid was like dude I have a
you know liquid acid in an eye dropper
where like we're like oh no way dude
let's do it it was like three dollars a
hit which was super cheap and then my
buddy Dan I remember he did like two
drops and I was like oh sweet dude he
was like all right let me do another one
anyway and I know I did too and then he
was like I want to do another one and
then he went
and
I went holy [__] dude I was like well I
can't let you do that by yourself and I
went
God we give back to the guy and he
looked how much was left in it he was
like dude he was like don't pay me
he was like you didn't get this from me
and then he just walked away from us and
then within 10 minutes dude within 10
you know as it takes like 45 minutes to
come on 10 minutes I'm I'm talking about
on another planet dude another [__]
planet just within five minutes of that
I lose Dan Dan's running down the street
like a lunatic let me see another planet
like what are you experiencing
um just extreme like um I mean like
I don't even remember most of the trip
but I remember I I saw a friend and that
got in their car and the lights from the
car it was like I was on a spaceship
dude it was just like the music and I
mean it was just like
the hardest I've ever tripped by far and
it's everything like the visuals The
Sounds the feeling but such intense such
an intense trip like scary it started
becoming really scary sort of going down
the road where you know everything is
everything like I sort of that was my
conclusion was like that life is death
and death is life and you know sound is
the same thing as a [__] table right
just being a [__] lunatic and um I
remember like starting to think about it
kept on coming into my head to kill
myself because I wanted as an experience
that I can only experience once it was
like just really scary [__] thoughts
and I tripped for two full days 48 hours
straight didn't sleep just kept on
tripping then I finally fell asleep and
then the next morning I woke up and it
was like I had taken a head of acid the
next morning but it was normal enough
that I was like so really for like three
days I tripped and when you were
tripping what did the world look like
um
there was just
like the world I mean
it's a great question it's a really
great question I'm trying to remember
what my perspective was and how the
world looked I remember being at a
Dunkin Donuts and just sitting there at
the table and just [__] thinking
about numbers a lot and just [__]
numbers yeah and everything was just
[__] brighter it wasn't dude it
wasn't pleasurable at all it wasn't like
are you thinking about numbers
um I don't know
I don't know I was just the numbers
words like coming into my head and I was
just repeating like fake math equations
that I that weren't real how do you know
they were maybe they were real I know we
wrote those [__] down what if you
wrote those badges down and someone like
Eric
what are you doing here where did you
learn this
oh my God this is the solution then they
run over to one of those [__]
Goodwill Hunting chalkboards
imagine all right bro imagine if that's
what ideas are when you're tripping what
if you what if you're catching like an
alien life form in in the in the it
comes in the form of an idea